hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I'm gonna show you
how to make a heat gun okami
japanese-style
pocket knife now I've had this knife for
over a year now I love this thing you've
seen me use it in a lot of videos I use
it just just an all-around utility knife
for cutting bait when I'm out fishing
it's one of my favourite pocket knives I
own a lot of pocket knives now this
video originally was posted on my other
YouTube channel to catfish and carp
YouTube channel so ivory edited it added
a little bit of extra footage and
hopefully you'll enjoy it so here's how
to make he gonna copy Japanese
okay this is the he gonna come II
japanese-style pocket knife this is a
traditional knife in Japan and you can
see it's a friction fold knife the
little thumb tab that helps you open it
up and the thumb tab also keeps the
blade from overextending so it locks the
blade in place and I'm going to show you
how to make this knife with a piece of
rebar sand sheet steel and a really
basic forging
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
one of my biggest regrets in this
project is I didn't spend more time
smoothing out the blade and polishing it
to prevent corrosion but it still turned
out okay and now let me show you how to
make the handle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so all we have left to do is we have to
temper the blade and then we want to
shape and polish everything all right
let's do it now you'll see me using this
magnet here the magnet helps me know
when I've heated the knife up enough for
the heat treating process what I do is I
put the knife blade into the fire I get
it a straw yellow at that point it
should be demagnetize so you hold it up
to the magnet and it shouldn't have any
draw at all and then I'm quenching it in
water now a lot of people tell me oh you
should quench it in oil
that's for high carbon steel this is not
high carbon steel this is rebar and so
what happens is when you quench it in
the water you harden it more
aggressively than you do with oil and
with softer steel that's a good thing so
that is why I heat treated with water
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there you go there's the finished
product not my pocketknife got an edge
on it it'll cut folds up really nice
tensions just right it's not perfect and
I think if I were to do this over again
I could do a better job maybe make it a
little bit thinner maybe use a quarter
inch rebar instead of half-inch rebar
but man I really like this this is gonna
be a fun knife is something I'll
actually carry with me and use all right
guys here's the knife it's one year
later it's held up really well I got a
lot of comments from people who said all
your using garbage metal rebar is not a
good metal and that's not true I mean
this it's plenty fine this thing is held
an edge I haven't sharpened it since I
made it and it is still plenty sharp I
use it for all sorts of things mostly
cutting rope and bait and just kind of
as a utility knife something you carry
with you in your pocket for whatever if
need comes along it's rusted a little
bit but that's because I didn't do a
very good polishing job on it and it has
just been a great fabulous knife I carry
this thing with me whenever I can I take
it fishing and use it to cut bait to get
sweat a lot that's part of the reasons
why I've had rust issues but it's just
held up extremely well so don't get
overly hung up about making sure you use
tool steel or 1080 high carbon steel or
whatever you know rebars not bad well I
hope you enjoyed this video if you'd
like to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click so
scribe and to click that Bell button so
you get notifications because we put out
multiple videos every week and check our
playlists I've got forging playlists
with all my different forging videos axe
restoration playlist with all my
different axe restoration videos so
whatever you're into on this channel
there's a playlist for you thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every week and
don't forget to hit that Bell button so
you'll get notified when we put out
another great video